we continue wayne newton week here on
good day he's performing at the flamingo
right now and of course we all know him
as just this incredible headliner
but like so many he started out with a
lot of hard work here's what he had to
say about his early days in las vegas
the education that this town
has offered me as a performer
is unequaled anywhere in the world
because when you
start out at the fremont downtown
which i did
at 15
we got hit with six shows a night
six nights a week 40 minutes on 20
minutes off six times a night it it's
like the farm team for a baseball game
where you have a place to be bad
and you learn and you learn
and so there isn't anything that could
happen on stage
that hasn't happened
oh i bet you can believe that and
certainly still such a hard worker now
but not doing those six nights six shows
mr las vegas has decades worth of
stories and experience join us all week
long we're honoring wayne newton and
diving into some favorite moments of his
we're also going to learn a little bit
more about the man who performed here
for 65 years wow
i feel like it's cool that he's doing
these smaller shows you can really sort
of get if you want to see wayne you're
going to see wayne you see whatever song
or plug in your iphone apparently
i think i saw one of the early early
versions of that idea of wayne at the
stardust
so that's how long ago that was wow he
was showing a lot of video clips at the
time and inviting folks to ask him some
questions so now this is even a smaller
room so i should probably go check it
out
you definitely should and i would think
he would play that better than the mgm
grand garden yeah it's a little
different by the way shout out to
yolanda martinez she won our wayne
newton
good morning
a lot more giveaways all throughout the
week for wayne newton week so we got
some cool stuff down the horizon so
shout out to yolanda thanks for watching